Cái stan và Afghanistan ngày 18,
bố tạm dừng có hỏi động quân sự,
nhân dịp et an phà tiê,
zip lệ lần kế thuộc tháng i ăn trải ra mở đàn của người hội giáo.
Thôi thích nguyên bằng kéo dài đến ngày 18,
được lưa ra thông địa gỷ của các nước chung dân của mọi rật xí ước,
cà ta và thống như ki,
hai bên được ở đây là cự chỉ chế chế dù là tạm thời,
sông cạnh báo sẽ đắt trả,
nếu bị tấn công trong thời gian này,
lên được bán tạm thời gian ra chỉ hai ngày sau gù không biết được sở,
trong sống xí quay người nghiệm mà tuy ủ mi tại Kabul,
Afghanistan gây thương vòng lớn,
chính quyền tên li bán cho biết bún trong lệ tạm,
nguyên thiệt mạm trong khi liên hạm quốc xa nhật ích nhất,
một trong bún vi vang ích hết.
Hai bên tiếp tục bất đồng về một tiêu bị tấn công trong sự viện.
Cà bún nói điện điện lạc gỡ sở giữ sư,
còn ít là mà bát cho rằng đây là nơi trở bu khí,
ua vê và lựa đánh bóng,
các chuyên ra thì nhận định khó sông mình tổng lập.
Sông đồ dưới hai nước lạc dẫn,
Afkanistan và Pakistan vũm phát tưởng nguy,
gió ít là mà bát gạo bục tật y bán chứa chấm được lượng bún trang,
và đến nay vẫn chưa có giấu hiệu hà nhật,
giù như bây nỗ lực tham giọng ở dài,
đặc biệt là Trung Quốc.